in this week's episode i along with my
good friend casey neistat tackle the
most frustrating and common problem of
being a creator
hey i'm dan mays i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i can confidently say that 99 of
all creatives experience this feeling
this kind of
nothingness it's the worst and i'm
experiencing it right now reason being
why i chose this question for this
week's episode so what is an idea and
what happens when we don't have them
how does this all work in the brain
are they just things that appear out of
nowhere or can you cook them up in a lab
well as of yet no one really knows what
ideas are made of but we've managed to
figure out a lot about brain activity
and how ideas form basically when your
brain is stimulated a large group of
neurons activate together we associate
or group sensations together for example
perceiving the color blue with feeling
cold books with knowledge and a dying
battery with anxiety these sensations
occur in your unconscious mind which
freud describes as the reservoir of
feelings outside your conscious
awareness these unconscious sensations
trigger neuron clusters all over the
brain working their way to your frontal
cortex which is your conscious brain and
when neurons fire here you become aware
of the stimuli and sensations forming a
thought or an idea this entire process
can happen in less than a second and
most of the time is stimulated by other
ideas or thoughts you've had before we
do this thousands of times per day both
consciously and unconsciously when you
have a new idea it's a configuration of
neurons that form a brand new pathway in
the brain but how do you come up with
one and how do you force your brain to
go down a path it has never before well
that's where i am i'm just so frustrated
it literally feels like my brain's empty
i've got all this gear and absolutely no
idea
what's up dude what you doing in here
buddy
dude i'm just frustrated i've got to
shoot this movie and i have absolutely
no idea what to do
writer's block right is black does that
[ __ ] ever happen to you
yeah it happens to me let's have a talk
to him if you don't already know this is
my good friend casey neistat who's been
described as the godfather of youtube
content we used to work together in new
york and he is literally the most
creative person i know if anyone
understands combating a creative block
it's him you don't have the idea right
zero idea okay so then the key to
pushing through writer's block is
for me you look at what you do have
and out of what you do have we'll birth
the idea
that makes sense
yeah what do you have
i've got a camera i've got the camera
the super slo-mo camera the phantom flex
4k oh feel it
oh
i know the phantom flex 4k
maybe you don't know the phantom flex 4k
here's a quick animation to explain it
why shoot on the phantom camera the
phantom is a high-speed camera meaning
that it's designed as a dedicated camera
for capturing every moment of
fast-moving subjects in crisp detail it
lets us see things that are too fast for
us to see naturally slowing down the
most mundane things can unlock a world
of awe and beauty accomplishing this
requires more power than regular cameras
and the phantom flex 4k has the power we
need standard cinema cameras shoot and
play back in real time at 25 frames per
second the phantom flex 4k can shoot in
4k at up to 1000 frames per second and
in 1080p at up to
2949 frames i'll be sticking to these
settings for the most cinematic results
okay so i got this camera
and uh what i've learned is it's not
about the camera it's all about the idea
[Music]
this
is what i need to break
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that felt like a real breakthrough
[Laughter]
what are you doing
what
what are you going to break next
[Music]
dude you threw that so hard
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i didn't know it came out both
sides it turns out that casey burns his
finger really badly during the shot that
is properly cooked
all right let's run it again
[Music]
burn shield
oh
okay
ah
well casey bandages up i just wanted to
say please subscribe to my youtube
channel for more videos just like this
and don't forget to put the
notifications below on them that's super
simple and thank you to discovery plus
for partnering up with me in the
creation of this brew show there's still
so many episodes to come and if you get
a d plus subscription you gain access to
every episode a week before it goes live
on my youtube channel if you sign up now
you get a 14 day discovery plus
promotion using the promo code danmace
this offer is valid until the 25th of
june 2022. so yeah click on the link in
my description to redeem your promotion
[Music]
do you feel like do you feel like we
broke through your writer's block
yeah
but at the same time
at the same time
i also feel kind of sad i gotta go to
the airport man
late
this has been fun
you wanna you wanna come give me a ride
maybe yeah i'm not gonna be able to
i don't have a and i can't
[Music]
has shown
in summary what i learned today is that
the best way to create when you have
zero idea is to return to the way that
you felt in that moment in time for
example when i have no idea i feel
frustrated i feel angry and helpless and
with the help of casey he urged me to
turn that into a video the idea then
became frustration and as soon as i
started and began moving and making some
form of progress it jumpstarted the
creative process this works the same for
writing poems creating music
drawing for art anything creative really
so yeah figure out how you feel and act
on that all you need to do is just start
[Music]
you